there are ways to waste your time until
departure like playing golf or reading
Jeffrey Archer some people spend some
proper afternoons on vogner Opera but
Friday by Rebecca Black is three minutes
you won't get back so I have tried to
write a song that sets a record for how
long a song can possibly go
you ready Matt it goes 100 that's right
let's do it again come on oh oh oh you
can sing along if you like
oh oh oh don't know if you're in a
library on public transport no oh we
need to get a few more of these done how
about we do three harmonies that way
we'll get it done a lot quicker all
right here we go
nearly hang well bang the drum and play
the victory bugle what you did just
there is sing a Google one with a
hundred big fat zeros buy yourself a
drink you hear oh well why complete this
pointless task
well now you're ready for the advanced
class the next idea is more complex
it's the ultimate time wasters test
we'll try to sing a Google
X it's gonna take a bit longer one oh
come on everyone
oh oh yeah why are you not doing it Matt
oh oh we're gonna mouth oh I thought you
liked Matt seriously what why give my oh
no because we managed just eventually to
get a hundred zeros but at Google
there's no way we're gonna get a googol
of zeroes to this point in fact even if
every single subscriber to numberphile
if they were all singing along which
believe me they're not but if the
approximately half a million subscribers
so that's five times ten to the five if
they all joined in and they did a
hundred each times ten for two then
that's only going to be five times ten
to the seven we will have hit five one
two three five six seven
that's half a million people pays
rubbish accurate alright let's try a few
other things right let's say that we're
singing about 1.50 per second I think we
can recruit everyone alive on earth
right now okay all of your number files
get hold of everyone alive on earth
about seven billion people right okay
and how about we have been singing since
the dawn of time how about we do that
and so that's about thirty point seven
five billion years can you do that in
seconds for me Matt around about three
times ten to the seventeen seconds okay
that's good that's getting a good number
up now so now we want to do some more oh
so how about we do want my old music
teacher used to suggest she used to say
sing with every cell in your body so
that's 75 trillion cells so pop that in
as well that's it good good all right
now that should be getting somewhere
near a googolplex that's what we're
aiming for that's what we're gonna beam
in okay if we had every single human
singing
so that's three times ten to the 41
which means you're up to around about
ten twenty thirty forty one then that is
not bad seriously that's like half I
mean we are halfway there look if we
carry on
we're just no we just need to dig double
no no [ __ ] look do half Grady do the
ding ding ding ding exactly what we're
not halfway there you don't you don't
compare the size of numbers by lining up
the digits alright it's not a king
Sudoku right you have that ding what you
do right is you can be the actual
relative sizes right so just to put this
into perspective if we had every single
human singing with every single cell of
their body and let's say a googol of
zeroes which is what we have to sing
let's say that was the size of the
entire known universe I'm using the
volume of the neuron universe not the
mass yes I'm going to include the masses
but if the universe was a googol of
zeroes every single human then sang with
every single cell since the dawn of time
we will have sung the proportional
volume i'll back it's pretty small
volume wise it's incredibly thin said it
that's it that's every single human
every single cell born of time and
everything else in existence is the
entire Google well that is disappointing
it's accurate well what I've learnt
today is that I can sing a google sing a
Google but not a googolplex
yeah happy day